des morceaux de métal déchiquetés c'est
tout ce qui reste de l'avion qui s'est
écrasé 6 minutes après son décollage
les 149 passagers et 8 membres de
l'équipage n'ont eu aucune chance
ils ont tous péri dans la tragédie nos
braves passé dios et le flight canada où
il est in 18 canadiens sont morts dans
l'écrasement qui a fait des victimes
d'une trentaine de nationalités partie
d'addis abeba l'avion qui devait se
poser à nairobi au kenya s'est écrasé
près de bischoff tout à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres de la capitale éthiopienne
le pilote avait demandé l'autorisation
de faire demi tour
tout juste avant le crash les causes de
l'accident sont toujours inconnues mais
la vitesse d'ascension de l'appareil
était instable selon les premières
constatations étaient à prendre ni
airplay c'était un nouvel avion avec des
pilotes expérimentés aux commandes
indique le pdg d'ethiopian airlines une
compagnie aérienne qui a bonne
réputation
l'avion en question un boeing 737 max
fuite avait été livré à l'entreprise en
novembre
fin octobre un appareil du même type
s'est lui aussi écrasé en indonésie peu
de temps après son décollage
boeing promet de collaborer à l'enquêté
pour déterminer les causes de
l'écrasement
l'agencé américaine de la sécurité des
transports
on verra une équipe d'experts pour
assister les autorités éthiopiennes ici
olivier bâche un réseau canada montréal